this is the bachelor Eagle shrinking  habitat and inadvertent poisoning has  caused a major drop in this majestic  birds population battlers and  medium-sized birds but they have a  wingspan of over 6 feet they have dark  black feathers under their white wings  with a red face and legs while endemic  to most parts of Africa they prefer the  urban woodland savannas or the  grasslands the name battle-ax is French  for tightrope walker and references  their distinctive flight pattern unlike  most birds they fly low to the ground  when hunting for prey they feed on small  birds and mammals but are also carrion  eaters  unfortunately pharmacal poison dead  carcasses to kill off predators and  battle lures end up ingesting the highly  toxic poisons this is the battle ooha  eagle  [Music]  you